hello neighbor happy to see you there
Marvel has released through the sdcc
iron fists trailer I don't know much
about iron fist I didn't know he looks
like I've only read like some Collider
articles about what he's supposed to do
what
creepy oh poor dear
am i waking up to a couple of asian
fellas
Wow hello Danny Danny tear devil like
what they really humanize him which I
really liked it wasn't like full-blown
superpowers same thing with jessica
jones like she's not full-blown
superpowers even though kilogram is you
know that's a rather superhuman ability
I feel like what the main character it's
still rather tone down Luke Cage we just
saw the teaser for that it doesn't look
like it's going super extreme and his
powers as well I feel like though with
the launch of the Doctor Strange movie
with Luke Cage amping it up in terms of
superhero abilities now you're appening
it up with an iron fist it has even more
magical powers that's a smart move in
terms of marketing of giving us that
direction now in terms of the Netflix
shows of now we can get even more
superhuman on our characters as we've
had time to settle into the netflix
Marvel world of daredevil jessica jones
now regain works at territory of
something maybe they might have saved
for for the movies but they're bringing
it to netflix to test it out in
different waters because from what I've
heard from iron fist I could totally
imagine iron fist being like an actual
film which is you know big and budget
explosions and all that crazy [ __ ] I'm
interested to see how they handle a
character with that much power on a show
like this I feel like they're gonna tone
it down a little bit but it might be
just the right amount this is just a
teaser of course still don't know what
the tone of the show is gonna be still
have no idea what this character is
really like yeah but I think it's a good
directions definitely got my appeal
anyway subscribe to my channel it's
called the real rejects stars me gregory
angelo alba the third the first two were
hybrids and listen I don't really crack
as many sex jokes these days however i
want to say iron fisting thank you have
a good night